to present the Oscar for make up the
legally bound Reese Witherspoon and Ryan
Phillippe
buck Henry who wrote the oscar-nominated
screenplay for the Graduate had the
following observation about makeup the
philosopher said beauty is only
skin-deep beauty in fact like ugliness
is generally applied at least two to
three inches deep at a very early hour
in the morning by masters of their trade
called makeup artists who combined the
techniques and styles of old fine
Renaissance painters with the dexterity
and enthusiasm of rich young Beverly
Hills plastic surgeons without
submitting to this daily ordeal actors
and actresses would look just like
people in documentaries then the brutal
truth is that in order to accommodate
all of this paint plaster for gel and
glue the actors must have in real life a
very small head about the size of a
coconut that's why you never recognize
them at the five-and-dime
the miracle workers nominated for best
achievement and makeup are greg cannom
and Colleen Callahan for a beautiful
mind Peter Owen and Richard Taylor with
the Lord of the Rings the Fellowship of
the world
Mauricio Snoopy and Alderson you ready
for Moulin Rouge
and the Oscar goes to let me read it
right you make more than I do go Peter
Owen and Richard Taylor for the Lord of
the Rings
these are the first Academy Award
and Richard Tyler
rhys-davies inter give me the dwarf and
required six hours of makeup starting
every morning at 4 a.m.
we have been on the most amazing journey
together to impart to the vision of
Peter Jackson the camaraderie of Barry
Osborne the incredible support of Marco
deskey the faces and bodies of the
actors who who went through hours of
makeup my journey as me made whole by
the the love of my partner Tonia Roger
and the wonderful genius of the small
group of young New Zealanders that have
gathered around us to make this so
possible thank you everyone for helping
us support this cause tonight it's
lovely day Sam I just want to say I
don't know why anyone gave me the job in
the first place I'm still recovering
from that I got an opportunity to go to
the most beautiful country on earth in
my opinion work with a genuine
fellowship of people and torture a lot
of actors thank I I can't thank the
Academy enough for this its is delirium
thank you
I'd like to take a moment to remember
the actors actresses producers and
directors who are no longer with us who
have gone up there you know the ones
filming in Canada hi I need to get well
soon we have five wonderful movies
nominated for Best Picture and they all
have one thing in common I wasn't in any
of them but that alone didn't get them
nominated our first nominated film is in
the bedroom a movie that was shot on
such a low budget it was originally
called in the double-wide now in the
bedroom I'm cracking myself up
in the bedroom is about a college-aged
young man who has an affair with a
single mom causing a huge fight with her
ex-husband it's huge
[ __ ] Spacek gets mad Marisa Tomei gets
slapped I'm telling you as deep baby
it's better than Jerry Springer ladies
and gentlemen in the bedroom